hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast powerful tools for in vitro
fluorescent imaging in cancer research
and Brenda Kelly chem lab roots and I'll
be a moderator for today's event today's
webcast is presented by Latin roots calm
a meeting social media site for science
professions and sponsored by immuno
chemistry technologies new chemistry
technologies provides quality laboratory
services and research reagents as a
contract service laboratory ICT
specializes in custom immunoassay
development manufacturing conjugation
lyophilization and consulting services
ICT is focused on Alyssa development and
has the knowledge to develop reliable
sensitive and specific tests ICT offers
a line of alyssa diamonds including
co-authors conjugate Stabler's and
sample dilutions designed to reduce
backgrounds increase specific signal and
improve the stability and shelf-life of
the alyssa ICT also offers a line
fluorescent reagents to measure kept
space activity apoptosis and cell death
in vitro before we start there are a few
effect instructions for this
presentation we want to hear from you
during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions or leave us a
comment answers are welcome to you can
do this by hitting a green Q&A button
the lower left of the presentation
window and typing in your comments and
questions will try to get to as many of
them as we can we don't have time today
we'll definitely follow up you can't
hear or see this presentation properly
let us know by clicking on the support
button at the top right or use the Q&A
button will try to make sure we resolve
any issues also we want to let the
audience know that this presentation has
been approved for continuing educational
credits if you want to obtain the
credits please click on me get your free
CD CME credits button located in the
lower left of your screen this will take
you to a page listing all of our
presentations and speakers please select
the appropriate CEC m.e button under
your presentation and follow the
instructions to play music
it now let's get late to today's
presenter we are proud to welcome Jackie
Carville Jackie Carville is the director
of marketing at in your chemistry
technologies where she focuses on
providing comprehensive user friendly
content to assist life science
researchers in optimizing their product
pipelines she obtained her undergraduate
education at university of
wisconsin-madison studying genetics life
science communication the more
information on Jackie's experience
please click on her name I'll now turn
the presentation over to Jackie great
thank you so much Brenda ah hi everyone
thanks again for joining me for today's
presentation is Brenda mention I'm
Jackie carvel online marketing director
and you know chemistry technologies
today I'm going to be going over a
variety of colorful tools for in vitro
fluorescent imaging how these tools work
and their applications for cancer
researchers just as a little FYI I've
and we're getting started there were a
few import issues with the side deck so
there might be a little off formatting
you'll see but don't worry we'll have
the slides available for your download
if you would like clarification and
really slides as well but tickets
started here today I'd like to give a
little background about immuno chemistry
technologies so here at ICT we offer
quality biomedical research reagents
including unique in hypnosis essays and
proprietary immuno kept amino acid
reagents we serve researchers all over
the globe and are dedicated to helping
our customers achieve results we were
founded in 1994 and women to Minnesota
which is located in the greater Twin
Cities area just south of New hapless
that we have the picture of here
originally I CT was a contract
laboratory focusing on custom
immunoassay development work and allies
of Eugene's we have expanded and
diversified our product lines over time
so today we're no longer just a contract
to laboratory for protein chemistry now
when your trusted supplier for apoptosis
essays
detection agents and customize the
development and other protein chemistry
related services our customers use our
products to study human and animal
biology and to investigate treatments
for cancer degenerative diseases and
other conditions affecting both humans
and animals so as a note all of our
products and services are designated for
research easily so I'd like to talk a
little bit first to get started today
about our lives of solutions products
these products are designed to help you
build a better esa our products address
the issues that typically occur during
the lives of development which involves
specificity sensitivity reproducibility
and shelf-life applaud our ICT coding
buffers blockers sample and Ashley
diluents conjugates stabilizers and wash
buffers all work together to minimize
the build-up of unwanted proteins and to
generate a very clean signal in this
area we do focus on providing several
key ways to optimize your lives of
assays so first you're going to want to
minimize your background and enhance
your signal-to-noise ratios for improved
sa sensitivity by promoting a strong
signal while minimizing nonspecific
binding and background noise next you
can also improve your precision and
reduce placate variability through the
use of our stabilizing buffers which
allow you to prepare plates in large
batches to use over time there but
therefore increasing your consistency in
providing that improved plate to plate
precision over extensive storage periods
additionally you can increase your assay
reproducibility by purchasing consistent
with your reliable source I also promote
a higher specific signal by minimizing
nonspecific binding through specialized
blocking and stabilizer formulations
products you can also stabilize your
protein conjugates through the use of
alkaline phosphatase and horseradish
peroxidase-conjugated stabilizers and
finally increase your shelf life of the
prepared microtiter plates by correctly
stabilizing absorbed
teams with reliable clothing and
blacking buffers resulting in plates
that can be stored for several months or
even years under the proper conditions
so to summarize all that information
eliza development really is a core
specialty of ours and want to work with
you to help optimize all your
immunoassay work so as i mentioned in
addition to our elijah services we also
offer a wide range of various custom
contract services as well so with
regards to the elijah services if you
like most scientists you really want to
focus on your field of study and don't
necessarily have either the background
or the time in order to develop a rugged
immunoassay test yourself so
pre-developed Eliza's and other amino
acids may be easy to run but the
development itself requires years of
knowledge of immunology and in protein
chemistry to really understand antibody
specificity and binding interactions and
that's where we come in at ICT so our
scientists are experts with many many
years of experience and you know assay
development and can also perform
optimization and testing services now
outside of amino acid development we do
also provide custom protein
lyophilization services so if you need
an agent bio your freeze-dried we can
reliably prepare that for you most ly
awful ization projects we can complete
those in about a week so there's a
pretty quick turnaround through on those
types of projects so with that said I'm
going to go ahead and move on to our
fluorescent probe product lines it will
be focused for the rest of the
presentation today our fluorescent
cell-based assays are for apoptosis
detection which is a form of cell
suicide which is mediated by a cascade
of proteolytic enzymes in the cysteine
proteases or caspases so cast these
assays live dead stained and
mitochondrial permeability assays are
all essential in the investigation of
cellular apoptosis
so what are we going through here in
today's presentation are these five
different fluorescent probe product
lines so first we'll go through Flicka
which is our product line for the
detection of active caspases magic red
for the detection of caspases and
collections in real time might opt to
assess mitochondrial health cytotoxicity
tests and flip for sehri including these
detection so I'm going to start here
today with one of our more popular
products which is our tickets now Flicka
stands for a fluorescent labels
inhibitor of caspases and measures cell
death by detecting intracellular caspase
activity and membrane permeability in
whole cells you do offer these kits in
three different color options for green
red and far away these kits as well as
many of our other assay kits will
discuss today are offered in different
sizes with varying numbers of tests it's
trial size options variables so as
you're assessing your particular
experiment and looking to determine what
the number of tests are we do define a
test as a 300 microliter aliquot cells
that are growing it no more than one
times ten to the six cells per
milliliter so just something to keep in
mind as you're thinking about your own
experiments as we go through some of
these essays today so in terms of cancer
research there are several advantages to
using Flippa and first look is the most
accurate and sensitive method of
apoptosis detection as it measures the
actual intracellular process of
apoptosis we have a cast base activity
instead of measuring side effect of the
process so second at the only method
that can detect cells in early apoptosis
and differentiate them from cells that
are in like apoptosis you really get
more specific information out of these
types of assays so here that that also
means that you can see how your cells
are responding to
and determine whether they're a pop
tonic necrotic or unaffected cells and
finally we do have a few different types
of Flickr kits available so depending on
your cancer research goals we do have
different options to suit your needs so
to assess apoptosis in general and look
at a variety of cafes activity we do
have flick up pollen castes acid kits
available if you'd like to target a
specific a space we have specialized
click achatz or caspases 1 2 3 and 7 6 8
9 10 or 13 so how does Flicka work a
flick of chromes as you can see the
little diagram on the left of the screen
are comprised of a test base affinity
peptide sequence fluoro methyl ketone
moiety that facilitates an irreversible
binding event with the targeted active
castes enzyme in the flores obtained
reporter so i'll kind of open up on the
side here that the different steps of
the process Flicka is a cell-permeable
direct probe which means that the cell
does not require licensing in order for
this essay to work it also does not
require permeable permeabilization
additional reagents or antibodies for
detection so to use Flicka you simply
add the non cytotoxic Flicka probe to
the cell culture media once Flicka has
diffused into the cells that will
interact with the enzymatic reactive
center of the targeted active cat face
and form an irreversible covalent bond
marking the cell with its fluorescence
signal there is no interference from
inactive forms of the enzyme during this
process the unbound flicker reagent is
washed away in the protocol and the
remaining fluorescent signal is a direct
measure of the caspase activity present
at the time of slip in addition you can
choose to visualize your cells of a
fluorescence microscope or you can
quantify the fluorescence intensity
using a fluorescence reader or flow
cytometers green fluorescent fam Flicka
probes excited for 88 and amid at
five-thirty the red fluorescent
footed Holmes excited at 565 and emit at
595 then finally the far red fluorescent
flicka's 660 probes excite at 660 and a
net head 16 so now that we know how the
process works I'd like to now take a
look at some different example data
results starting with some flow
cytometers data here what you're looking
at here our results from three different
flickin products so first is our 660
Flicka polycast based product which is a
far read for us in probe and that's the
graph you're seeing all the way on the
left there and what you're looking at
there are jurkat cells that are treated
with scarce born this is a chemical
known to induce apoptosis so it makes
for excellent positive control the red
line here are our untreated cells which
in this case you'll classify as our
control occupe control population and
they are not induced so these cells are
not a pop topic the black line on the
flip side will be our experimental
population so these are the induced
cells and the impact on excel line and
as you can see across all of these
products there's a strong shift in terms
of fluorescence intensity among the
treated cells in terms of these other
graphs the middle graph is showing a
green fluorescence Flicka kit and the
end graph is showing another far red
with a kit however this is measuring
pyroptosis instead of eight hot dosas on
this slide we have some sample quick
reader results here again we're looking
at the jurkat cells that are treated
with stairs going and we're then read on
the plate leader with excitation and
emission at 515 um hi patty here we were
staying with our polycast based
detection kit so again almost with a
colleague caste-based kids look at cafes
activity more in general as opposed to
looking at one specific a space and
again in our induced cell population you
can see that there is a strong increase
in fluorescence signal
so finally we do have here some sample
fluorescent microscopy results and on
the left in that first image there you
can see some thp warning cells that are
duly stained with our family kapali
cascades acid kit and hooks to stain the
DNA in cells blue and if we look at this
image you can see three different cells
that are pictured there the one in the
middle is the one we believe to be a pop
tonic as we can see green fluorescence
for the cast based activity we also see
in that middle sell some bright blue
spots in the cell indicating that the
cell is beginning to die as the DNA is
fragmenting the cell in the upper left
corner isn't aquatic as we see no green
and we do see some scattered blue then
the cell down at the bottom right there
we consider to be live and non a pop
tonic as it lacks and green fluorescence
and it has one really bright
concentrated blue spot that does
represent the DNA so the second image on
this slide on the right is a colorectal
epithelial cells that were infected with
salmonella and here the authors of this
particular paper use a Salmonella strain
that is constitutively expressing and
cherry so the cell Manila appears red in
this particular image here the authors
then used our family cacaface 1si to
look for the activation of pyroptosis so
that will stain green in men and you can
see that these cells in the middle that
are heavily affected with Salmonella you
also do have a strong activation of
caspase-1 indicating that this
salmonella is the salmonella infection
here is causing these cells to undergo
pilot ptosis
so with that said I'd like to now go
ahead and move on to our line of magic
read essays so our magic read reagents
are self permeant fluorescent substrate
probes that are used to quantitate both
cafes or cassettes and activity in
cultured cells now these magic read kits
do you allow you to monitor your cast
base orkut epson activity in real time
so you can watch your cultured cells
undergo apoptosis these kids are not
Eliza's and they do not use antibodies
but instead they are self coming at
substrates specifically targeted by the
active enzyme and we do offer a few
different types again of these magic
read kits including those that assess
activity of effects and VK or l as well
as assessing the activity of caspases 3
and 7 so in terms of cancer research
elevated cathepsin enzyme activity in
the serum or the extracellular matrix
often signifies a number of different
cat illogical conditions so cook up some
mediated diseases g include Alzheimer's
numerous types of cancer autoimmune
diseases like arthritis and we
accelerated breakdown of bone structure
as seen with some different forms of
osteoporosis specifically upregulated
epson's B&L activity have been linked to
several types of cancer including cancer
of the colon pancreas ovaries breast
lungs and skin upregulation of pepsin k
has been shown in lung tumors this upper
increased production k activity has also
been shown to be linked to some
degenerative bone diseases including
osteoporosis and postmenopausal
osteoporosis so in general assessment of
elevated levels of extracellular
connexins has proven to be a very
important part masticate prognostic
indicator of cancer chemotherapy out
past
so logic read works when the target
substrate peptide sequence is linked to
read floorboard and magic red which is
also known as Russell violet 4s is read
once the substrate is cleaved by the
specific enzyme and in this case that
that specific enzyme would be either
your caspases 37 or your collections be
care out whichever one understood if it
is cleaved by an active protease the
release magic red floor or will
fluoresce stay inside the cell and often
will aggregate within my stones so the
conception X up if cadets and enzymes
are lysosomal the CAF spaces are not and
we'll see that in some of the example
data as well so as this protease
activity compresses and more substrate
as cleave the red fluorescence signal
increases so you can actually watch this
color develop over time the reactions
are fast starting within 15 minutes so
you can watch the fluorescence develop
over several hours the typical
incubation time for this assay is about
15 to 20 minutes so you can watch the
cells then through a microscope and take
pictures of the progress or you can
choose to read the total fluorescence of
the sample with a fluorescence plate
reader and magic read does excite at 542
590 and admits at greater greater than
in six so now we'll go through a few
examples of magic read results here so
on this slide you can see an example of
what a magic read time-lapse might look
like so here rat fibroblasts were used
with the café's with the magic redcat
phase 3 and 7 kit here so the red
fluorescence avisas becomes brighter as
cafés activity and apoptosis progressed
over the time period of the experiment
and we do have the nice images here that
depict that but if you're interested in
magic read in this type of time-lapse
progression we do have a nice video of
this same data on our websites you can
watch those cells on get brighter and
brighter as they undergo a consciousness
um but here's another good example of a
positive reception be magic read essay
in thp-1 cells and so you can see on the
left there where it's fluorescing read
you can see that the cadets easy is
concentrating in the lysosomes of the
cells and finally this image here is a
nice example of dual stinging of
camptothecin induced mcf-7 breast cancer
cells here we used both magic red and
hooks sustained so the experimental
cells in this case or stained with magic
red for about 30 minutes and then washed
twice in PDF and then they were also
stained following that with hooks for
about 10 minutes and so again the magic
red staining here for the epson activity
and the hooks to stain the DNA in the
cells so you can see the a pop taught
excels bearing the orange license on the
bodies with less intense blue nuclei the
nami pop taught excel still do have
those bright blue nuclei and they don't
have any of that orange lysosomal
staining here so in this particular
experiment it was determined that the
treatment that was being applied to be
breast cancer cells was indeed killing
myself so now I'm going to move on to
our might opt product line and our kids
here which allow you to quantitate
mitochondrial functionality in apoptosis
so detection of the mitochondrial
mitochondrial permeability transition
event provides an early indication of
the initiation of cellular apoptosis so
this process is typically defined as a
collapse in the electrochemical gradient
across the mitochondrial membrane so
these kids will detect a change in
mitochondrial men
potential kits are fast with incubation
typically only being 15 to 20 minutes
and we do offer these kits in three
different forms this jc1 tmre and TMR
any kids and i'll talk through over the
next few slides what the differences
between those those types of kids are
the first I'd like to talk briefly just
about why looking at mitochondrial
health is important in terms of
different disease research it's
definitely important because the
depolarization of this inner
mitochondrial membrane can often lead to
an opening of mitochondrial permeability
transition for this results in the
leakage of inter membrane protein that
facilitate apoptosis because this
mitochondrial dysfunction has been
closely tied to such neurodegenerative
diseases such as Alzheimer's Parkinson's
lateral sclerosis mitochondria do remain
an important organelle of study for a
variety of different diseases in terms
of apoptosis analysis so as I mentioned
we do have some different types of might
opt essays which work in slightly
different ways so the first I'm going to
go through how our might opt jc1 sa
works and these jc1 assays were our
original might opt reagents and they're
based off of a fluorescent cationic dye
which penetrate cells and enters the
healthy negatively charged mitochondria
here aggregates and then flores's orange
or red and as a mitochondrial membrane
potential collapses might opt jc1 is
diffused throughout the cell and once
disperse the reagent assumes a modern
Eric form and then flores's green so
this change in fluorescence can be read
with a fluorescent complete reader full
site ometer or fluorescence microscope
might opt jc1 excites at 488 and amidst
at 90
so would be sample might opt jc1 results
jurkat cells were treated with scarce
porn for two hours to induce apoptosis
and other cells were treated with DMSO
as the negative control these cells were
then stained with the might opt jc1
agent for about 20 minutes and then wash
and if you look at this data image you
can see that the two cells on the left
are two healthy cells so you can see the
mitochondria there with polarized inner
membranes fluorescing way on the right
of this image we see three cells that
are a pop tonic cells and in contrast to
the two solid former left here we can
see that the mitochondria are at various
stages of permeability so that they do
exhibit reduced red fluorescence and
increased green fluorescence as the
might opt jc1 reagent disperses
throughout the cell so our other types
of might opt essays our rtm RM and tmre
essays and these different from JC one
and that they are based on different
cationic fluorescently distribution dies
so the TM RM is based on tetramethyl
rhodamine methyl ester um we're at the
tmre is based on tetramethyl rhodamine
fo of ethyl ester so just two different
dyes that are used they're similar to
what we discussed with the GC 1 kits
after the reagent is added it does enter
the negatively charged mitochondria it
accumulates and then it flores's away
and when the mitochondrial membrane
collapses and a pop taught excels the
tre or TMR m dyes can no longer
accumulate within those mitochondria and
then the dye disperses throughout the
cells the overall solar fluorescence
levels drop dramatically and this event
can be easily detected by monitoring the
amount of emitted fluorescence which can
be done through a flow cytometer plate
leader or
microscope so the might opt tmre and TMR
em excite optimally at 549 and 548
respectively and they do yield excellent
results using a 488 laser so optimal
emission for these are 574 and 573
respectively as well so here we're
looking at some sample results and you
can really see the difference between
the healthy and a pop taught excels with
those depolarized a pop taught excels
exhibited much lower levels of
fluorescence and so you can really see
here to not only the difference between
the healthy and dying cells in this data
example but just the difference between
the readouts of the TM re and the TNR
kits versus what we looked at as the
readouts or the JC one case so I'm going
to shift gears again here to a different
product line of ours which in you know
and I'll introduce our cytotoxicity
assays so he at ICT we have now
developed two different assays to
measure cytotoxicity so if you're
looking to measure necrotic and membrane
come to my cells you can opt to use our
basic cytotoxicity test however if
you're looking to further distinguish
apoptosis from necrosis leading to a
more accurate assessment of cytolytic
activity we do offer a total
cytotoxicity test so with this total
cytotoxicity test at least ten percent
more cytolytic activities often measured
when a pop taught excels are also
identified with this test kit so these
kits provide a direct measurement of
cytotoxicity rather than using an
indirect indicator such as the release
of LVH or ATP enzymes and there's no
need to lace yourselves for the
cytotoxicity studies since these essays
do not
use any radioisotopes in them such as
from Ian 51 they are much safer and less
expensive much more cost-effective than
other types of assays for cytotoxicity
so there's also no waiting with these
kits you can directly measure subtler
the connectivity without having to wait
for encipher ways so in terms of cancer
research cytolytic activity is a very
important process for eliminating
intracellular pathogens and cancer salas
so this process is accomplished through
various immune effector mechanisms
including natural killer leukocytes
natural killer activity is facilitated
by nonspecifically lai Seng infected
targets through the use of natural
killer receptors so recognizing igg
bound to specific antigens on the target
cell surface natural killer cells may
also induce apoptosis in target cells
the activity of natural killer cells and
their effect on target cells is
frequently studied in immunomodulation
experiments so first I'm going to go
ahead and run through how our basic
cytotoxicity tests work using this nice
little diagram we have first you purify
your target cells and stings with CFS E
which is a green membrane stain to
distinguish them from unstained effector
cells during flow cytometry analysis
next we'll go ahead and add your
effector cells or toxic agent to the
target cells and these effector cells or
toxic agent will act on these target
cells in this step next and go ahead and
add the red live dead stain which is 7a
ad and this stain will enter cells the
compromise membranes in ptosis and the
800 sis and bind DNA it will not enter
any cells with intact membranes so the
final step of this process here is to
run
and then analyzed using flow cytometry
to quantify two populations of target
cells in each sample for we live target
cells and the necrotic cells so the
percentage of cytotoxicity can then be
calculated by counting the number of
dead target cells which are stained both
read and read and then dividing that by
the total number of live target cells
which are the all gravy cells so to
expand on the capabilities of this basic
cytotoxicity test and now we're going to
take a look at how the total size
cytotoxicity test works and the first
two steps of this kit are the same which
is the purifying the target cells
staining with the cffc and then adding
the effector cells where this protocol
starts to differ is that in the next
step you'll go ahead and add the orange
red SR efrika apoptosis detection
reagent so this will go ahead and enter
the cells and then buying two active
caspases if the cells are not a pop
tonic it will go ahead and wash out of
the cells then at the next step we could
add our live dead stain the 7a ad again
which like in the basic kit is going to
enter the cells with intact membranes or
with some compromise membranes excuse me
in necrosis and laid i took late
apoptotic cells and go ahead and bind to
that DNA 780 d steyn is not going to
enter yourselves with intact membranes
and then finally if the last step here
you'll run your controls and analyzed
using flow cytometry to quantify for
different populations of target cells in
each sample so this includes cells in
early apoptosis which are not detectable
by any other method so these four
populations that we'll be looking at
include live target cells early
apoptotic cells late apoptotic cells and
necrotic cells
so now we'll go ahead and analyze some
flow data here to both the basic and the
turtle cytotoxicity tests so you can
really see the breakdown of these
different cell populations of interest
and how that displays in infosys
coventry data so on the Left I do have
first a commoner data for the basic
cytotoxicity test and here I've gone
ahead and we've created a plot with CFS
E and said maad and all the target cells
are initially stained green so the
entire population of target cells can be
counted in the r2 and r1 quadrants after
the effector cells and red lie dead
stain were added all the dead target
cells arrest red shifting them up the
y-axis and clearly distinguishing them
from the live target cells so the dead
target cells are in r2 and the live
target cells are in on one so the other
two quadrants here in this graph the
live effector cells are in our for and
the dead effector cells are in r3 so if
we're going to go ahead and use the
total cytotoxicity test kit we would be
further analyzing we r 1 and r 2
quadrants from the basic to isolate the
pop taught excels so a total
cytotoxicity test plot at the right has
been extrapolated from the r1 and r2
quadrants at the left so once the green
target cells from r1 and r2 have been
baited you derived a plot of poly
caste-based apoptosis from agent sr
Flicka versus the live dead viability
stain 70 AD in this white total type
total cytotoxicity plot and here we can
now analyze are four different
populations of cells which are our live
cells and three populations and cells in
the death process so you can see in
quadrant one
that there are the live cells stained
green quadrant 2 has early a pathetic
cells that are stained both green and
orange quadrant 3 has lately popped
attic cells that are stained green red
and orange and quadrant 4 has necrotic
cells that are stained green and red and
I just want to point out that quadrant 2
is of particular interest as no other
method such as P I staining or other
assays can identify this additional
population of cells the overall takeaway
here is that researchers can now include
a pop taught excels in their analysis of
cytotoxicity which does lead to more
accurate results so now I'd like to go
ahead and cover the final product of our
presentation today which is our Fliss
product line now if Lisp reagents or
fluorescent labeled inhibitors of serine
proteases our self permeant fluorescent
inhibitor probes used to quantitate
serine protease activity and cultured
cells our flip assays are available with
green or red probes serine proteases are
defined by the presence of a serine
residue at the active center of the
enzyme and the most characterized
enzymes of this type are trypsin and
chymotrypsin so all living cells do have
a base level of Kemet trypsin-like
enzymatic activity which will vary with
their physiological state of the cell as
well as my cell type however activated
serine proteases play major roles in
several different functions including
apoptosis markers of tumor malignancy
diagnostic and prognostic indicators of
rest personnel moans and Megan head
person elements as well so serine
protease activity is also altered in a
variety of other cell mediated diseases
which can be related to transplant
rejection and infections as well so for
our flip kit you'd simply add the
reagent directly to the cell culture
media and
day in wash because ICT spliffs
inhibitors are self permeant they will
efficiently diffuse in and out of all
living cells if there's an active Kemet
repinlike enzyme inside the cell it will
prevail Utley buying people's lisp
inhibitor and retain the green or red
fluorescence signal within the cell
cells containing lower concentrations of
time' trypsin-like and enzyme activity
will retain a lower level of
fluorescence compared to the cells
containing higher concentrations of this
effector enzyme component there's no
interference from pro enzymes nor
inactive forms of this enzyme in this
particular assay know if your treatment
is activating chymotrypsin like staring
proteinases positive cells will
fluoresce brighter than the normal
baseline negative cells allowing you to
clearly differentiate these populations
so to tie all the way back to the
beginning of this presentation you can
use these twists kits in conjunction
with our Flicka kids which is what we're
looking at in most particular figure so
what was done here is that hl-60 cells
were treated with camphor dicen and
apoptosis you sir for three hours and
then stained with our green BAM twists
and protease inhibitors and our red SR
Flicka polycast ace inhibitor for an
hour these cells were then washed and
analyzed on a scanning laser sight
ometer and in this photo cytometry data
we can see that cells with active serine
proteases will stain green along the y
axis and sells the active cat faces
stained red along the x axis we can then
see from some of these microscopy images
here that there is a wide range with
cells that range from a which are only
green cells that are showing serine
protease activity b c and d which are
duly stained cells showing both serine
protease activity and half space
activity and then finally e which are
only staying red or
cascais sexism so with that that wraps
up the variety of for us probes I wanted
to talk about today um went through a
lot so to recap we talked through Flicka
for detection of active caspases magic
thread for detection of caspases and
productions in real time might opt to
assess mitochondrial permeability and
health cytotoxicity tests and first for
ceremonies detection since we covered a
lot of ground i did want to point out
the variety of resources that we provide
from ICT we recently began our first ICT
webinar series so we do have our first
webinar recording available on our
website and you can register for our
upcoming webinars there as well we'll
also have some nice videos coming soon
to show these kits in action and really
show you how easy it is to run through
these assayed protocols so I check back
soon for those those videos that should
be up shortly we update our blog with
helpful articles tips and tricks for all
things you know a flavor rated and
finally we also have an extensive
variety of technical documents that are
hosted on our website each of these kits
to help you and support your work this
is a nice picture of our team here at
ICT our team takes great pride and
excellent customer and technical support
we offer very fast shipping and if you
have any questions about our products
you can often talk directly with the
inventor of the product to help
troubleshoot your process for our
international customers we do have a
large established global distributor
network to assist you in getting giving
you our products as fast as possible and
we also do have a guarantee on all our
products so if they don't work me we're
happy to refund your purchase there so
that's about all the content I have here
today my contact information is as
follows if you'd like to reach out to
you any questions or comments otherwise
I can take some questions at this time
thank you very much Jackie for that
excellent presentation bringing all that
information to us before we get started
on audience questions I just want to
remind our participant how they can
submit their questions questions for
Jackie can be submitted through the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window will try to get
to as many questions as we can I know it
always takes just a minute for people to
get their questions entered so I'm going
to give our audience time to do that
right now again as you can see on the
slide there's Jackie's contact
information if you need to reach out to
her in addition as Jackie mentioned the
slides will be available as a PDF
download any resources that you might
need so much just give our audience just
another minute for some of the questions
online
okay I don't I don't see anything in our
queue I'm going to just turn it back
over to Jackie for a minute with any
final comments words of advice or any
other information she has for our
audience thanks Brenda yeah just to wrap
up you know thank you again so much for
doing this for a presentation I hope you
found the continent hopeful if you do
have any questions on any of our product
lines whether it's the fluorescent probe
to be discussed today are Elijah
solutions or any of our custody services
please don't have time for you now you
can get all your questions answered
thanks again for joining us and that
wants it back over to Brando to wrap up
thank you again jackin as well as our
sponsor immuno chemistry technologies
for bringing this webcast today and
making it possible as i said before
slides are available as a PDF there's
something that you didn't catch this
webcast will also be available for
on-demand viewing through march of 2016
will receive an email from labret salur
tenue when the blood cast is available
for replay and we would invite you to
throw with that female to any colleagues
might have missed today's live event
thank you again for logging in and
participating in today's webcast see you
next time